this is one of Ukraine's top Commanders  Andre Kovalchuk led a major offensive  that we captured the southern city of  Hassan  he's now focusing on new targets but  also preparing for a possible fight back  by Russia one year on from The  full-scale Invasion people think maybe  on the anniversary the 24th of February  Russia will try again to attack from the  north from the east from the south are  you anticipating that could happen  [Music]  um  [Music]  the general said Russia's Vladimir Putin  May ultimately order millions of his  soldiers to fight  [Music]  and would he be able to deal with that  [Music]  um  Army  [Music]  this was the commander as he toured her  son city after its liberation last month  he says Ukraine will win this war it's  just a matter of when  is  as a decorated and highly experienced  officer he knows that could well mean  the fiercest fighting is yet to come  Deborah Haynes Sky News in southern  Ukraine